Integrity means thing on us
and having strong moral principles.
A person with integrity we have ethically
and that's the right thing.
Even behind closed doors,
you may ask
how do we demonstrate integrity at work?
There are some simple ways to start.
Respecting the privacy of colleagues
in private conversations,
communicating honestly,
taking responsibility for your actions,
making promises to keep
supporting your organizations value
with or without recognition,
acknowledging your colleagues
when they perform high quality work
and being trustworthy. After all,
employee who can demonstrate integrity in the workplace
enjoy great working relationships
with supportive and light minded colleagues.
You will be more likely to earn promotions
and enjoy the satisfaction of being a valid team member
too. That's all we want to share about integrity at work.
We wish you all the best in your working life. Thank you.